merci merci mon cher françois merci à
toutes et à tous de m'accueillir ici a
dit d'elle c'est je le confesse la
première fois que je viens à guidel
mais
c'est sûrement pas la dernière mais je
vous fais observer déjà que si je vous
vois ici
tout est tous réunis
nombreux
ce que nous n'avions pas pu faire
l'année dernière à la même époque
certes avec encore des masques
certes
en ayant eu recours au pass sanitaires
enfin nous sommes là
tous ensemble
et partout je me déplace et dieu sait si
je me déplace je recommence à
voir des gens réunis et heureux d'être
unis
et ceux ci mesdames et messieurs
est sans doute dû
à la formidable mobilisation
que tous ensemble
le peuple français dans son immense
majorité
la très grande résilience
qui l'a mise dans la lutte contre cette
crise sanitaire inédite qui n'est pas
fini nous devons être vigilants
rester mobilisés mais dans la gestion
révèle en tout cas lorsqu'on se compare
avec tous les pays du monde mesdames et
messieurs que nous n'avons pas à rougir
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première évidemment pas la
seule raison
qui fait que je suis très heureux d'être
parmi vous à vos universités d'été en
cette fin de matinée mon cher françois
mes premiers mots seront pour toi si tu
le perds mais voilà
c'était peut-être pas complètement donné
en dépit de
nos origines est proche on va pas
disserter sur le gaz comme et le
béarnais après tout ce que tu as dit sur
les voisins tout à l'heure nous
n'aurions peut-être pas tout à fait la
même opinion mais c'était peut-être pas
complète pas écrit un certain nombre
d'années
que nous nous retrouverions ici ou
ailleurs
à partager ensemble des moments
politiques très important pour notre
pays les choses sérieuses
se connaissant me connaissant en epub
partagé beaucoup de choses dans la
convivialité
mais c'est lui destin du pays dont il
s'agit
et quand je vois ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
ce dont témoigne ma présence parmi nous
je le dis je le vis elle ressent comme
un progrès majeur dans notre histoire
politique
oui
si on parle comme tu l'as si bien fait
de références littéraires les hommes
ajouteront aujourd'hui les femmes de
bonne volonté
peuvent se retrouver
alors que des lignes politiques
souvent factices les ânes ont trop
souvent empêché
c'est à emmanuel macron que nous devons
mesdames et messieurs cette évolution
formidable je le dis pour notre pays et
pour notre démocratie
[Applaudissements]
puisque je suis devant vous
une formation politique historique
m'adressant à des militants à des
combattants des engagés
je voudrais vous dire cette fois ci en
qualité de chef du gouvernement
combien celles et ceux des ministres qui
sont dans mon équipe et qui
appartiennent à votre formation les
fentes honneur sont là devant vous
[Applaudissements]
venez boire
cali geneviève mark jacqueline saura
jeudi c'est une belle équipe ils ont
leurs convictions chevillées au corps il
très bien pour le pays je voulais vous
le dire les yeux dans les yeux
et je voudrais aussi
m'adressant aux
parlementaires qui sont là de votre
formation
les députés d'abord cher patrick
président du groupe
sénateurs membres du parlement européen
combien il m'est précieux de travailler
avec vous à
c'est pas toujours un long fleuve
tranquille mais la vie en général et la
vie politique quelle est elle
mais outre
que nous savons toujours le retrouver
sur l'essentiel
outre que vous avez compris
que la vie politique c'est le collectif
et qu'à un moment donné c'est un très
beau mot nous devons trouver des
compromis françois a parlé d' équilibre
sont des
beaumont nous passons tout le temps des
compromis pour vivre ensemble
leur façon d'être leur parcours à ses
parlementaires
souvent imprégné dans le terreau de
notre république constitue sachez le un
apport essentiel à cette belle majorité
parlementaire dont j'ai l'immense
honneur d'être le chef merci à vous
alors évidemment il n'a pas
échappé n'échappe à personne du reste
mais évidemment pas à moi que nous
sommes dans un moment très particulier
de l'histoire de notre pays
pas seulement
disons le ca compte un peu parce que
s'approche chaque jour davantage une
échéance en rendez vous majeur pour
notre pays majeurs
mais aussi bien sûr parce que la france
l'europe le monde sont confrontés
à une crise inédite
sur le plan sanitaire les historiens
nous ramène en
1918-1919 la célèbre grippe espagnole
et sur le plan économique
vous le savez faut remonter à la crise
de 1929 et à la deuxième guerre mondiale
pour que notre taux de croissance est
été
aussi fortement amputé
d'un moment exceptionnel et il se trouve
mesdames et messieurs
je m'adresse à vous au modem ce matin je
le dis toutes les composantes de la
majorité
du premier ministre parlementaire aux
militants il se trouve que c'est nous
qui sommes en responsabilité pour faire
face à cette situation exceptionnelle
selon me dit quand je me promène quand
je vais plaisir suprême pour moi au
contact de mes concitoyens
je ne sont pas
hostiles me dit voilà c'est le premier
ministre un plupart d'entre eux on
n'aimerait pas être à votre place
et je leur répond inlassablement
comme sans doute vous pourriez le faire
à ma place
détrompez vous madame
détrompez vous
monsieur
rien n'est plus beau
d'abord que de pouvoir servir son pays
et particulièrement quand il est dans la
tempête et c'est ce que nous nous
efforçons ensemble de faire
c'est pourquoi la première chose que je
veux vous dire ce matin le premier
message
qui est le mien le peuple français nous
regarde vous connaissez bien le peuple
français son histoire ses
caractéristiques
c'est pas un peuple très facile à gérer
il a sa personnalité son caractère et on
ne changera pas ça
quelque part c'est heureux faut toujours
être fier de son peuple lui dire qu'il
ya des choses à changer à faire évoluer
c'est le boulot du politique mais ne
nous trompons pas de diagnostic c'est un
peuple très politique ils nous observent
ils aiment bien envoyé des fléchettes à
ses dirigeants
c'est surtout une façon de les tester
dans l'adversité
de mesurer leur sens d'intérêt général
leur capacité à faire face
nous devons faire face
nous regarder nous observe
est ce que
nous devons faire c'est le premier
message je le répète c'est travailler
travailler travailler encore au service
de nos concitoyens et de notre pays ils
voient bien malgré toutes les polémiques
malgré tout les réseaux sociaux
malgré tout ce qui se dit il s'est
distingué les choses j'en suis convaincu
il peut regarder les résultats
et si je vous demande ce matin comme je
ne cesse de le faire
autour de vous
vous qui avez évidemment comme militant
la fois du pays la fois de la politique
chevillée au corps si je vous demande de
dire ce que nous faisons
ce qu'il y a beaucoup à dire parce que
nous faisons beaucoup pour notre pays
si c'était faux mesdames et messieurs il
le verrait parfaitement il le verrait
parfaitement si nous n'étions pas
ensemble
comme je le suis personnellement je suis
derrière le président de la république
en première ligne donc je dois plus que
tout autre montrer l'exemple montré
l'exemple si nous n'étions pas à leur
service et au service du pays à chaque
minute engagé jusqu'au bout de nos
forces pour faire face à la crise si
nous ne le faisions pas avec sincérité
et avec humilité
cette crise est inédite sans doute
avons-nous pris des décisions parfois
inadaptés qui ne l'a pas fait à part
celles et ceux qui n'ont jamais exercé
aucune responsabilité et dont vous
observerez qu'ils sont logiquement
d'ailleurs les premiers à donner des
leçons aux autres
ne donnons aucune leçon
travaillons et montrant à voir ce que
nous faisons notre pays
notre pays mesdames et messieurs
peut-être
dans les circonstances que nous
traversons fier de lui-même je ne dis
pas ça pour le gouvernement de la
république
quoique
et la majorité qui le soutient sans
faille et les militants qu'ils
accompagnent au quotidien
je dis ça parce que c'est la réalité
que nous n'avons aucune raison de nous
auto flageller
et que par rapport à ce qui se passe
ailleurs oui je le dis c'est aussi une
façon d'être fiers de notre pays à côté
de la collection des déclinologues et de
tous les gens qui vous disent que tout
va mal il fait bon vivre
dans notre pays en ajoutant
immédiatement
en ajoutant immédiatement
que notre devoir de dirigeants de
politiques de responsables c'est de
veiller à celles et ceux de nos
concitoyens à celles et ceux de nos
territoires
dans la situation demeure très difficile
et que nous devons impérativement aider
à s'en sortir c'est ça l'action publique
mais non
ai-je besoin de vous rappeler que ce
travail
j'ai parlé du volet sanitaire explique
aussi que notre pays
est celui qui en europe je pourrais dire
dans le monde en tout cas en europe est
celui où la croissance économique est la
plus forte
mesurez bien
si j'étais venu m'exprimer ici à guidel
l'année dernière en d'autres termes si
les considérations sanitaires ne m'avait
pas empêché le disait ton
que je serai le premier ministre
confronté au taux de chômage le plus
élevé de l'histoire au nombre de
faillites le plus élevé de l'histoire un
effondrement
quasi complet de notre économie et de
notre société par les mesures que nous
avons prises par l'esprit de résilience
de nos concitoyens par la solidarité
nationale qui s'est exprimée nous avons
tenu le choc
et bien sûr je sais faut jamais négliger
qu'on donne très souvent la parole à
ceux qui protestent de façon véhémente
radical a dit votre président vous devez
croiser tous les jours comme moi des
membres la majorité silencieuse
auquel je voudrais avoir une forte
pensée devant vous aujourd'hui tout
simplement oui mesdames et messieurs
nous devons travailler
nous devons continuer inlassablement à
protéger nos concitoyens à renforcer et
transformer la france
c'est un impératif
collectif
cette relance économique je le dis
par le travail
par l'investissement
c'est une priorité absolue
vous vouliez je vous le répète je vois
les débats qui sont devant nous
non sans quelques curiosités j'entends
que les mêmes
qui nous ont dit voilà un peu plus d'un
an lorsque j'ai présenté le plan de
relance
expliqué que nous étions petits joueurs
quand monsieur byden souvenez vous a
présenté le sien
100 milliards c'est trop peu
c'est indispensable et ça produit des
résultats et voilà les mêmes qui
aujourd'hui disent est ce un
qui semble nous reprocher de dépenser
trop comprenne qui pourra
la réalité mesdames et messieurs la
réalité mesdames et messieurs
je le dis devant françois bayrou c'est
que
nous n'avons aucune leçon à recevoir
sur les questions d'équilibré des
comptes publics et de préservation de
l'avenir
c'est un sujet extrêmement sérieux mais
que nous disent même les experts les
plus sévères je pense au fmi que rien ne
serait pire alors que cette crise
sanitaire économique n'est pas terminée
que de faire comme on l'a fait par le
passé
succéder
à la relance l'austérité ça ne
marcherait pas
et nos finances publiques croyez le bien
s'en trouverait
encore plus affaiblie et dégradé je le
dis très clairement à mes concitoyens
nous devons continuer à investir à
travailler et nous mettrons toutes nos
forces dans ce défi voyez bien
d'ailleurs l'actualité du jour
l'actualité du jour c'est quoi nous
avons réussi à recréer un nombre
d'emplois considérable le taux de
chômage est déjà revenu à celui d'avant
crise alors même qu'on annonçait cette
perspective au mieux à la fin 2022
dès la fin de cette année au plus tard
au début de la suivante nous aurons
reconstituer le stock de richesse
nationale
perdue du fait de la crise sanitaire
depuis 2020
nous avons mieux que n'importe quel pays
préserver le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens est aujourd'hui que me dit
on où est l'urgence
pour voir
ces emplois ainsi créés et c'est pour ça
croyez moi par la formation par la mise
en oeuvre de l'assurance chômage par les
négociations de branche
nous en avons fait l'impératif majeur de
cette rentrée ramener le maximum de nos
concitoyens au travail et à l'activité
faire de notre économie
la plus transformatrices celle qui se
numérise celle qui se dé carbone celle
qui reconquiert sa souveraineté c'est
comme ça que nous rembourserons nos
dettes et que nous comblerons nos
déficits car tel est bien aussi mesdames
et messieurs notre objectif nous devons
nous devons travailler pour les
française et pour les français elle a
simplement
jusqu'au dernier jour pour ce qui
concerne mon gouvernement et la majorité
qui est devant nous et en même temps
évidemment nous devons éclairer l'avenir
comme nous avons commencé de le faire ce
qu'attendent vous le savez nos
concitoyens ce n'est pas simplement que
nous fassions face que nous gérions la
crise du mieux possible avec les
résultats que vous savez il nous demande
d'en tirer toutes les conséquences les
plus structurelles de données comme l'a
si bien dit françois un sens un cap vers
l'avenir
nous devons être au rendez vous de tous
ces défis
la transition écologique la souveraineté
économique la cohésion sociale et
territoriale
c'est tout l'objet à la fois du plan de
relance
des lois que le parlement a adopté et va
continuer jusqu'au bout adoptée oui nous
avons chevillée au corps que nous devons
avoir une économie plus forte plus
résiliente mieux adaptée aux enjeux du
monde de demain parce que nous croyons à
la justice sociale à notre modèle social
et que nous nous devons lui donner les
moyens de s'adapter aux enjeux du
vieillissement de la pauvreté et de
l'activité c'est cela que sous
l'autorité du président de la république
mon gouvernement
la majorité
a entrepris et continuera inlassablement
à mener jusqu'au bout
une société
plus humaine françois l'a dit plus
fraternelle et je le dis devant le modem
aussi plus européenne car j'écoute comme
vous
tous les débats qui se déroulent nous
devons revendiquer notre identité
européenne
la souveraineté de la france à laquelle
je suis comme vous particulièrement
attaché elle passe par la souveraineté
européenne le 1er janvier prochain nous
y travaillons d'arrache-pied il se
trouve que la france va prendre la
présidence française de cette union
européenne c'est un moment très
important
je vous le dis
je suis fier que ce soit emmanuel macron
qui soit à la barre est à la manoeuvre
dans ce moment là
peillon s'est fixé des objectifs
ambitieux pour faire valoir une vision
de la france dans l'europe qui est
toujours la sienne
respectueuse des autres partenaires
mais qui caractérise notre oeuvre
commune
nous travaillons par exemple ardemment à
pouvoir faire aboutir
pendant cette présidence française de
smic européen
c'est tellement important pour nos
concitoyens cette europe sociale nous
voulons par exemple faire avancer
peut-être aboutir
cette taxe carbone aux frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne pour
dire qu'il n'y a absolument aucune
raison comme l'a dit françois tout à
l'heure
que alors que nous sommes parmi les plus
vertueux
sur le sentier de la transition
écologique rentrer en europe des pays
des produits par dons venant de pays qui
eux sont moins respectueux de ses règles
qui du coup
sont moins chers et qui viennent
concurrencer nos producteurs nos
agriculteurs
c'est ça le chemin européen de refaire
et puis mesdames et messieurs
il y a évidemment des projets
l'action les résultats
il y as je ne cesse de le dire depuis
mon entrée en fonction
une méthode
une méthode une façon de faire
parfois vous savez
j'ai dit lorsque je me suis présenté
devant les parlementaires devant les
députés les sénateurs à la faveur de ma
déclaration de politique générale que je
serai l'homme de l'intendance quelques
gros mots
je vois beaucoup de champions des idées
mais pour faire société pour donner du
sens de la conviction que le com en
a au moins autant d'importance que le
poids
alors oui c'est vrai c'est vrai je
revendique devant vous
je vous invite
revendiquer autour de vous
que
nous devons être
le parti du rassemblement
plus que jamais dans la crise est là sa
ble ment alors que
des discours radicaux
pourraient donner l'illusion
d'apporter des solutions plus que jamais
notre pays n'a besoin d'être rassemblée
plus que jamais croyez moi
c'est pas facile
car comme l'a dit françois
il faut apprendre à vivre ou réapprendre
parfois à vivre les uns avec les autres
j'ai la conviction par mon histoire par
un monde passé par
aussi ce que je sens au plus profond de
moi-même
que
s'être cicatrisation du pays mais aussi
son développement passera par les
territoires je le dis souvent cher
jacques l'idiot l'illustrent
j'y vais beaucoup dans les territoires à
la rencontre de mes concitoyens quand
nous étions
vendredi dans l'yonne pour traiter dans
les sous-préfectures j'aime la france de
sous préfectures de la question des
déserts médicaux
nous je le rappelle au passage qui
sommes les premiers à nous être attaqué
à la question du numerus clausus c'est à
dire au fond du problème
quand j'étais mardi c'est à dire trois
jours auparavant en seine saint denis
pour m'occuper notamment des quartiers
de la politique de la ville en réalité
je fais la même chose
en toutes circonstances nous menons une
politique cohérente
ressouder la france
écoutez
je voulais dit tout à l'heure
faisons le avec bon sens avec humilité
avec sincérité
n'oublions jamais que la première vertu
d'un politique monsieur l'ancien
ministre de l'éducation nationale c'est
la pédagogie
expliquer ce que nous faisons surtout
comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
nous avons fait nous faisons et nous
ferons beaucoup pour notre pays
a semblé fédérer
écoutez
éclairer l'avenir
au fond vous savez
au delà des débats idéologiques et
vous ne voyez se dérouler sous nos yeux
sans que j'ai besoin de les commenter
les français voient bien
au fond
nous devons d'abord leur donnez nous
mêmes l'exemple en nous rassemblant
c'est le chemin que nous prenons
quand d'autres sans doute
laissons-leur
afficheront leurs divisions
nous devons le faire dans la clarté et
dans la sincérité
je vois des gens aujourd'hui
pour sans doute
conquérir un certain type d'électorat
radicalisent leurs discours
au point de n'être plus eux mêmes
les français s'en apercevront soyons
nous mêmes
sans fierté
excessive
tout est là
à l'écouté de nos concitoyens contente à
nous apprendre
de ce rassemblement fort
dont nous devons montrer le chemin
résultera n'en doutez pas un
élargissement
nous devrons faire venir à nous
élargir
au bout du bout vous savez
au delà des débats idéologiques
légitime nous sommes une grande
démocratie
toutes les idées se respecte mais
n'oubliez pas
particulièrement dans ces temps troublés
dans ce monde plus incertain que jamais
plus menaçants
qu'au bout du bout
nos concitoyens se poseront la question
qui est le plus capable
qui est le plus à même
de rassembler
la nation france
de porter les belles valeurs historiques
l'identité
de la france
de la représenter le faire prospérer
ses intérêts dans le monde
ce sera comme toujours
dans ce rendez vous avec nous-mêmes
qu'est une élection présidentielle la
question
ultime
alors si nous continuons à travailler
à être humble et aller coûte à éclairer
l'avenir
a rassemblé à commencer par nous mêmes
de plus en plus
alors
on peut espérer pour notre pays et pour
2022 je vous remercie